Michigan State University will pay half
a billion dollars to settle claims from
survivors of the biggest sex assault
case in sports history 332 women sued
Michigan State for allegedly ignoring
complaints about disgraced former dr.
Larry Nasser he abused female gymnast
and other athletes for decades and will
be imprisoned the rest of his life dr.
Jon LaPook has been following the story
John good morning good morning the
details of the settlement are still
being finalized but Wednesday Michigan
State's trustees approved its basic
terms some survivors say they feel
vindicated by this settlement but they
also insist their fight for justice is
far from over it feels like a huge
victory Jeannette antolín was sexually
assaulted repeatedly by Larry Nasser
when she was a member of Team USA from
1995 to 2000 she was one of the first
elite gymnasts to publicly accuse him of
abuse when we interviewed her for 60
minutes last year there's stuff that you
just can't take back the trauma that's
been done has been done and a lot most
of us will live with it with for the
rest of our lives and no amount of money
can change that the settlement will cost
Michigan State University 500 million
dollars 425 million will be split among
332 survivors who sued the university
the other 75 million is set aside for
victims who may come forward in the
future we're going to be working extra
hard that makes certain nothing like
this ever happens again
MSU kept Nasr on its payroll despite
complaints he abused victims under the
guise of providing medical treatment
recently on earth video shows NASA
deflecting blame onto his victims during
questioning by campus police
the MSU settlement raises the stakes for
USA Gymnastics which used NASA as its
team doctor it also faces lawsuits along
with the US Olympic Committee and
coaches Bella and Marta Karolyi
attorney John manly represents a hundred
and seventy-five survivors they should
be very afraid of those women getting up
and telling their story to a jury
because their story is horrific and they
have been treated like human garbage
manley says a retired judge will decide
how much each survivor will get but
Genet antolín and others their fight at
its core has never been about getting
money it's been about getting to the
truth and holding responsible
individuals and institutions accountable
John thanks well become mad at me in
this case well and I think that's an
important point that John makes that the
victims have have said that this is
really - about about Michigan accepting
responsibility it's such a large payment
but in some way it's accepting
responsibility for for ignoring this
abuse for decades it's a message to
other schools to address these issues
right away - that's exactly right you're
on the hook for this yeah don't be on
the lookout for it